Kiki Palmer can you imagine if that was
your mom she is a newborn she's 29 years
old you know you you've seen those old
scrapbooks of your parents when they
first got married right do you guys do
your parents have one I don't know but
I'll look at like old pictures my mom
and dad hanging out together having a
good time can you imagine then you see
your mother you're like flipping through
okay and boom your mom's ass is on the
picture at an usher costume your
memories of like them first married is
your mother grinding on another man now
I don't know if women understand how
crazy this is
we have the worst generation of wives
and mothers like guys it is no wonder
men are walking away from Marriage when
they look at the marriage Market they're
like I want a wife where do I buy one
and this is what they get
a wife that looks like a hooker